hello everyone and welcome back to
norway chess the classical tournament
where pretty much only armageddon games
are decisive this is the first game
they're finished from round three
richard rapport versus magnus carlsen
and uh basically the classical game in
the armageddon game they all ended well
within two hours uh the classical one uh
wasn't uh well wasn't anything crazy
with 16 moves so not a lot and the
magnet sacrificed a piece for for a
perpetual draw
forcing basically armageddon as
well there really wasn't
all that much to be done there uh and uh
uh well it's just the
the the classical wasn't all that
impressive but the armageddon game is it
features two really awesome positive
video moments so you guys are going to
enjoy that
but uh all you know the the game itself
is really awesome so without further ado
let's check it out uh richard with the
white pieces opens with the g3 and as uh
robert is hungarian i am not very well
versed in pronouncing hungarian names so
if any of you guys are from hungary
perhaps uh send me an email with the
correct pronunciation so i know uh to
use for future videos because i've heard
quite a lot of them and all of them are
pretty much different so g3 going for
the
king's fin shadow opening uh and magnus
replies with the d5 a very principle
decision if black decides to play on the
flank uh you will of course grab the
center as much as possible we have
knight to f3 c5 now bishop to g2 and now
knight to c6 regarding the e5 square
preparing e5 as well uh we have castles
by white and now e5 so the king's indian
attack
we have d3 and now bishop to e7 and now
usually white goes knight beat to d2
here but richard wants to surprise
magnus and he plays knight to the a3
it's not a new idea uh and uh well
richard himself played it already
against another very strong player he
played it this year against fabiano
corona
going to get to that we have bishop to
e6 just continuing development e for now
and magnus closes the position with the
d4 you could also just capture here and
go for some sort of a queen trade but
that doesn't really offer black that
much even though magnus only needs a
draw to win the match for example
captures and captures uh no one trades
the the queen here because if you
capture the queen rook captures here uh
wha what did you really achieve you
can't castle queen side if you play
knight to f6 uh we're gonna play b3 put
a bishop here uh put more pressure on
this pawn the knight can come to c4 in
the future uh so
it's maybe not all that much for white
in an armageddon game but black really
gets nothing and magnus of course knows
what he's doing in positions like these
so d4 that we have knight to c for now
offering bishop captures knight in order
to
mess up white's pawn structure but
there's no reason to do this magnus
continues development queen to c7 and
now knight to g5 going after the light
square bishop so magnus gives up the
dark square bishop makes sense all of
his spawns are on dark squares so if you
have to choose of course you will keep
the light square bishop uh bishop
captures on g5 bishop captures on g5 and
now we reached the point that uh
rapper already had uh in his game
against uh caruana in in his saint louis
blitz uh that ended in a draw where b5
was played by fabi but here magnus plays
f6 and here is where we deviate from
that game and no it's still not a new
position uh here bishop to c1 is a known
move but here in the game we have bishop
to d2 by rapport and it is now as of
movie 11 that we have a completely new
game
so how will magnus continue well he's
obviously going to castle queenside and
start an attack against the white king
which is a very double edged especially
since he's playing with the black pieces
and he only needs a draw
choosing such a such a sharp opening but
it's something that we often discuss
uh that when you only need a draw and
you try and play defensive chess uh you
will lose that game because that's not
what you usually do and you don't really
uh you know
know how to find your way around
positions like that even though magnus
is very strong he prefers playing
attacking chess uh we have h5 now
preparing h4 he wants to open up the uh
the king side here and f4 now of course
you're waiting for magnus to castle
queen side and at some point of course
if this bishop comes to f4 it will be
very good for white
we have h4 as planned now queen to e1
when captures uh
white doesn't want to capture back with
the h1 he wants to play queen captures
here and put even more pressure on this
diagonal so h captures on g3 queen
captures on g3 now a lot of pieces
attacking this e5 square
and magnus has to decide he wants to
castle queen side or he wants to first
eliminate one of the attackers of the e5
pawn
maybe not such a bad idea but he decides
to keep the tension he castles queen
side and now we have b3
now if he ever captures on c4 now uh
rapper might even decide to play b
captures and open up the the v file uh
to be used for attacking the the black
king so here uh we have knight to h6 by
magnus and this is uh again uh
completely disregarding uh the safety of
his king because uh you have the king
and the queen on the open c file plus uh
you know if it opens up then uh
rook might occupy it and you you might
have some problems but this is
armageddon uh white has only 10 minutes
black has seven but black is uh very
happy with the draw
and there is increment but only starting
from move 40. so you have to reach that
this is only move 15. uh knights to h6
and now f captures an e5 the capture
fest on e5 is starting we have knight
captures on e5 knight captures an e5
with f captures on e5 and now rapport of
course wants to open up
the c file and he plays c3 we have
knight to g4 by magnus going after rook
captures on h2 but now c captures on d4
he invites magnus to go for this idea
uh problem is if you go rook captures on
h2 uh what are you really doing d5 is
coming and what what do you play now the
where is the bishop gonna go yeah you're
gonna move the bishop we're going to
play rook 8 to c1
and this position will simply explode
and there's no real weight to pile up
here on the king side if you try rook dt
h8 it's not really a lot that the bishop
is doing wonders here to defend the the
this position we can just play d4 bust
open the position completely and that's
just it if if we trade we can even trade
queens it's not a problem and now if
king captures even bishop to f4 check
now the rook will will get picked up so
this is all good for white uh so instead
after c captures on d4 uh magnus plays
uh the well the sort of the the bravest
move in the position he plays e captures
on d4 and he allows rapper to grab hold
of this diagonal uh what black should do
here is rook captures keep this position
closed and now uh maybe even uh
you know shift the uh pressure of the
position towards the center of the board
but he played this and rapport very
happily accepts this we have bishop to
f4 now forcing carlson's queen to move
with queen to e7 uh and not rook 8 to c1
putting pressure on this pawn here but
also having a very
tricky idea
uh magnus has to play defensive here
with b6 but that's uh just conceding to
a worse defending position b4 and the
position opens up so magnus played
actively he played the g5 here he wants
to be the one that attacks but chess
doesn't work this way so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
seemingly winning move for a rapport
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on winning black's
queen or rather
giving up your two rooks for the queen i
say seemingly winning because you know
this is armageddon and it's not as easy
you've won some material but not the
game so rook captures on c5 uh
congratulations to everyone who found
this you are an excellent assessor of
any position uh we have queen captures
on c5 and now rook to c1 this will win
black's queen so magnus gives it up on
c1 with check bishop captures and now he
plays a rook calpers on h2 and uh
the tension is very high for upward of
course he's playing against the world
champion uh and a simple move like
bishop to f3 uh can do wonders for uh
for him because you're threatening to
remove the defender of the rook and if
the rook moves you're just going to
capture on g4 although it seems
simpler than it is because the rook can
move now attacking the the bishop here
we're going to capture on g5 and now the
the game continues but still this would
be very much winning for white for
example knights the e3 if the knight
moves if you don't want to give up a
piece then the rook falls and this will
be more than sufficient for white
however he played bishop captures on g5
first attacking the rook here and this
allows magnus to shift the rook into the
attack we have rook to g8 now comes
queen to d6 nicely unpinning and now
trying to give up the the g5 bishop for
the e6 bishop and this will of course
come with check so magnus goes for this
there's really nothing better we have
rook captures queen captures with check
and king to d8 and the problem for
magnus is uh he's down to one and a half
minutes on the clock whereas rapport has
some five and a half minutes on the
clock uh queen to d6 with check king the
e8 and now uh well now rapport makes a
terrible move uh what he should do uh
but it's not it's not as clear because
there's uh you know a lot of tension of
course you're playing the world champion
but uh i'm gonna show you what white
needs to do in order to play this uh
correctly uh you have to go queen to b8
to check and now if the king moves or we
of course pick up the pawn it's a free
pawn why not this comes with check king
the g6 now queen the a6 check and
finally after king to h5 you have to
play queen to e6 but figuring all of
this out in
you know in such a such a quick game is
not easy because now the knight can't
move the rook will fall the rook doesn't
really have anywhere to go the king
doesn't have any good squares so we'd
see something like rook to c5 going for
rook to c1 check but now queen to f7
with check king h4 now queen to f4
guarding the c1 square and again not a
lot of moves for black after you move
the rook let's say rook to g5 now we
play king to f1 and now we start slowly
making progress in the game
uh as black really doesn't have all that
much to do we can even start pushing our
pawns here but that's very very
difficult to spot i mean from such a
position expecting that something like
this even exists so he played bishop to
f3 and he allows magnus a beautiful
trick uh well i say a trick it's
actually a combination uh that saves him
the game so feel free to pause the video
for the second time and try to find this
magical move while i give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that you
have to momentarily
give up the defense of the rook on h2
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the move is knight to e5
with check and it seems uh weird because
well king captures an h2 is happening
but this uh just runs into king captures
an h2 and knight to f3 check and if
you've ever studied
some chess end games or maybe some uh
weird chess positions you know that this
position with the knight and the rook
where the rook is cutting off the king
from from entering the game is is a
known drawn uh
drawn repetition because if king h1 this
is checkmate rook the g1 the knight
covers these two squares and if of
course you go up the board then we just
keep happily hopping around with the
knight knight g1 checking h4 we're gonna
play knight f3 check defending the rook
delivering check king has to go back we
go back king goes here we deliver
checking goes back and so on it's a it's
a repetition so rapper sees that there's
uh no point in doing this so he tries
king to f1 uh but it's not much better
not just knight captures on f3 and okay
we have queen to e6 check we're gonna
win this knight it's not a problem king
to d8 now queen to f6 with check we have
king to e8 and now queen captures on f3
but although this seems like uh uh like
making progress it's really not you
could just continue checking the black
king and then get a draw but uh
black or you know draw only favors black
uh as this is armageddon and black wins
the game if it's a draw so rapport has
to pick up the knight uh but now we have
rook to c5 by magnus going after a nice
um a rook to c1 check as the other rook
is cutting off the king completely from
the second rank uh magnus is very low on
the clock if he wasn't uh the the the
seemingly simple rook the g8 wins on the
spot there's no defense against uh rook
to f8 because you can move the king and
you can move the queen but nothing helps
if you move the king then just rook the
g1 check and the white will have to give
up the queen and if you move the queen
where are you moving the queen to there
is really no good square you can't
remain on the f file and if you play
some like queen to d1 then just rook h1
check and i mean it's again completely
winning for black so here uh magnus
played rook to c5 it's kind of the same
idea he wants to deliver or checkmate or
win the white queen king the g1 now
attacking the black rook we have rook
captures on h2 again it's the same idea
and now queen for guarding against rook
to c1 check so rook c to c2 now he can
happily start the delivering checks here
but also just rook to a1 will be deadly
uh so queen to b8 check we have king to
e7 and now queen the e5 check and
there's nothing that can be done here
white can only continue repeating moves
uh as uh well uh rookie one or rook c1
just win the game for magnus so king to
f7 queen to d5 wait to check we have
king to g6 queen to f5 with the czech
king g7 now queen g5 check king h7
there's no way to increase the pressure
you don't have any pieces or pawns
surrounding the black king queen h5
checked king g7 queen to g5 check and it
was in this position on move 42
that the players agreed to a draw as
there is no hope for for white to make
any progress here and if he pushes and
gives black just one move he's gonna
will get checkmated very easily
uh so yeah another armageddon for magnus
and another victory for him uh but uh
we're we're not gonna show the standings
just yet as i'm gonna show at least one
more game from round three but it's only
richard uh who won a classical game uh
so he is actually the leader of the
tournament uh uh so far uh it's much
better to win as you get three full
points for for a win and only half an
extra point for winning the armageddon
game if you draw the classical uh so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
really crazy one uh robert had a very
nice chance of beating magnus but it
seems that magnus just always wiggles
out somehow but as they say in chess
luck favors the strong
uh so yeah uh once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank uh f
lightheart suhas raja chandra gupta uh
livestream him uh jeff langley and
samuel camulli for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day